a major construction project causing a
lot of traffic headaches
right near the las vegas strip thank you
for joining us at six i'm brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez so if you drive
near the strip and sahara you know how
busy that intersection can be
it's even busier this week due to a
major road paving project
that the project extends from sahara to
elvis presley boulevard near circus
circus and resorts world
that's where joe moeller picks up a
story about when the project will be
done
and also why you can expect more
construction on the strip in the near
future
it's a nightmare the north end of the
strip is looking more like a parking lot
there's a lot of traffic definitely a
lot of traffic
a long waiting time las vegas boulevard
from elvis presley to sahara is down to
one lane in each direction
to be patient because it's it's a
nightmare and they're not
i don't see anybody out here kind of
directing traffic helping maybe move it
along
this is part of a bigger project this
porsche will last through friday
from seven in the morning until two in
the afternoon crews are repaving which
is why the northbound lanes are closed
over the next several months work will
take place all the way to the 215
beltway which includes traffic signal
upgrades new street lighting and
pedestrian crossing improvements
i avoid to come from here always i used
to the back road eating cab drivers know
to avoid the area
especially now resorts world drive and
genting boulevard are providing some
relief there's definitely a better way
plugging in your destination into an app
such as waze may get you through the
area a little faster
it's very hot sweaty
ready to go people sitting in it monday
say pack your patience
avoid the area avoid that area as you
mentioned
there was some alternate routes a desert
inn paradise convention center other
ways to kind of get around that
but be aware that the magic fashion
trade show got underway today at the
convention center
that's going to run through wednesday so
you might see some increased traffic
by the convention center as well